[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
a excepción de una station marker y como
se esperaba la convención del partido
demócrata eligió a joe biden como su
candidato para enfrentar a donald trump
en las urnas en noviembre y él aceptó
les contamos los detalles de este
encuentro y la filtración de las
declaraciones de emilio lozoya el ex
director de pemex que vinculan a tres ex
presidentes con la trama de sobornos de
odebrecht desató una guerra mediática en
méxico un vídeo del hermano del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
recibiendo dinero mancha el discurso
anti corrupción del mandatario
y américa latina superó las 250.000
muertes por coronavirus la mayoría en
brasil y méxico- y en medio de la
carrera por desarrollar la vacuna la
nación azteca y argentina acordaron
producir la de la universidad de oxford
para toda la región visitamos el
laboratorio argentino a cargo de hacerlo
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal es oficial yo bailé
me enfrentará al presidente de donald
trump en las elecciones del próximo 3 de
noviembre
el ex vicepresidente fue confirmado por
los delegados durante la convención
nacional demócrata que por primera vez
en sus casi 200 años de historia se
desarrolló de manera virtual debido a la
pandemia
precisamente bailén arremetió contra
trump y su gestión del cob y 19 y
prometió acabar con el virus
el presidente que no asume la
responsabilidad que se niega a liderar
que culpa a los otros que acoge a
dictadores y aviva las llamas del odio y
la división él se despertará cada día
creyendo que el trabajo se trata de él
nunca de ustedes esos son los eeuu que
quieren para ustedes su familia y sus
hijos irse mucho el encuentro demócrata
también confirmó a kamala harris como la
aspirante a la vicepresidencia así la
senadora por california se convirtió en
la primera mujer afro en aspirar a este
cargo de la mano de uno de los dos
partidos tradicionales con opciones
reales de ganar
harvey se entregó un discurso poderoso
en el que se concentró en exaltar que
bailén es el candidato contra la otra
pandemia que azota a eeuu el racismo
entonces podemos hacerlo mejor y
merecemos mucho más we must
debemos elegir a un presidente que nos
ofrezca algo diferente algo mejor y que
haga el trabajo importante
con un presidente que nos una a todos
negros blancos latinos asiáticos
indígenas para conseguir el futuro que
queremos colectivamente futuro colectivo
y los pesos pesados del partido
demócrata hablaron en esta convención
para respaldar la candidatura de bailén
entre ellos los ex secretarios de estado
colin powell john kerry y hillary
clinton uno de los discursos más
poderosos fue el del ex presidente
barack obama de quien bardem fue el
vicepresidente y tan inusual como toda
la campaña estadounidense de este año
obama arremetió contra camps y llamó a
los jóvenes a defender la democracia
nunca esperé que mi sucesor a adoptar a
mi visión o continuara con mis políticas
si esperaba por el bien de mi país queda
nostrum mostrará algo de interés en
tomarse en serio y trabajo
primer cambio que llegara a sentir el
peso del despacho y encontrará algo de
reverencia por la democracia que se
ponía bajo su cuidado pero nunca lo hizo
brinda a perder
y trampa estuvo muy activo a lo largo de
la semana respondiendo ataques a través
de twitter le preguntamos a nuestra
corresponsal en washington diana
castañeda cuál es la conclusión de esta
convención de cara a la de los
republicanos
hola qué tal una de las principales
conclusiones que deja esta convención
demócrata sin precedentes convención
virtual es que no quedan dudas sobre la
unidad del partido demócrata o por lo
menos así lo quiso mostrar el liderazgo
demócrata ya que vimos unidad entre los
más progresistas unidad entre el ala
liberal pero que no comparte digamos
algunas de las plataformas de bernie
sanders que se mostraban anteriormente
pero vimos con todos los discursos
representación de la comunidad lgtb de
representación de los afroamericanos
representación de los líderes e
inmigrantes del partido demócrata así
que esta es una de las principales
conclusiones la segunda queda muy claro
cuáles van a ser los temas principales
de la plataforma y políticas que va a
presentar yo bailé en un programa de
reconstrucción de la economía para
generar más empleos después de la
pandemia en materia de inmigración una
reforma migratoria también un amplio
plan para luchar contra el cambio
climático y por supuesto propuestas para
acceso en materia de salud debido a la
pandemia aún más después de la
administración del presidente donald
trump y la tercera conclusión es que hay
que esperar que esta unidad se traslade
a las urnas y por eso este era el gran
mensaje para todos los demócratas para
los votantes para que salieran a las
urnas sin tener miedo a hacerlo a través
de correo o en persona para no seguir
digamos esta campaña que ha iniciado el
presidente donald trump de desconfianza
en el correo postal quedan cerca de dos
meses y medio para las elecciones de
noviembre 3 y allí veremos si el partido
demócrata cumplió su objetivo de lograr
esta unidad en los votantes
y vamos a bolivia para revisar otras
noticias del continente que usted
debería conocer esta semana
en plena campaña presidencial el
gobierno interino de ya nine años
demandó nuevamente al ex presidente evo
morales esta vez por mantener una
relación con una menor de edad la joven
tiene ahora 19 años pero ya nine años
asegura que la relación comenzó cuando
evo era presidente la joven le dijo a la
policía que están juntos desde mayo
pasado aunque lo conoció a sus 16 años
y el expresidente de colombia álvaro
uribe vélez renunció a su silla en el
senado luego de que la corte suprema de
justicia le ordenara prisión
domiciliaria como parte de la
investigación en su contra por presunto
soborno a testigos y fraude procesal la
división abre un debate sobre si será la
corte suprema la que llevará a su caso o
si se traslada a la fiscalía liderada
por francisco barbosa un amigo personal
del actual presidente iván duque
heredero político de uribe
y en medio de las críticas al gobierno
brasileño por los incendios en la
amazonía el vicepresidente en hamilton
mural luego que la selva estuviera en
llamas sin embargo el instituto nacional
de investigación espacial detectó más de
3000 incendios en las dos primeras
semanas de agosto cinco veces más que en
el mismo periodo del año pasado
[Música]
vamos a méxico andrés manuel lópez
obrador basó su campaña en la lucha
contra la corrupción y la austeridad
pero un vídeo filtrado por la prensa
mexicana pone ahora en entredicho este
discurso pues en él se ve a su hermano
tío recibiendo dinero de un hombre que
ahora es un funcionario de su gobierno y
en el momento era asesor de
comunicaciones del entonces gobernador
del estado de chiapas el presidente dijo
que se trataba de donaciones del pueblo
para su revolución
el discurso contra la corrupción del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
fue puesto contra las cuerdas por este
vídeo en el que ve a su hermano pío
recibiendo alrededor de 90.000 dólares
de david leones john es funcionario
actual del gobierno de evo 30 es el
vídeo revelado por el portal de noticias
latinos se grabó en un restaurante en
2015 y se conoce al mismo tiempo que
méxico es sacudido por las revelaciones
de emilio lozoya el ex director de pemex
que vinculan a funcionarios de las
anteriores administraciones con la trama
de sobornos de la constructora brasileña
odebrecht el presidente mexicano dijo
que el dinero que recibió su hermano
provenía de donaciones voluntarias son
aportaciones
y fortalecer
el movimiento
en momentos en que la gente
era la que apoyaba además el mandatario
pospuso el nombramiento de david león el
hombre que entrega el dinero como jefe
de la distribuidora estatal de
medicamentos hasta que se aclare la
situación estos vídeos que presento
flores de mola
deben de entregarse
a la fiscalía
general de la república
es decir el señor law le debo la debe de
presentar una denuncia
o los expresidentes
o sus representantes el vídeo se conoció
apenas un día después de que también se
filtrara a la prensa una declaración de
lozoya en la que señala a los ex
mandatarios felipe calderón y juan
carlos salinas así como altos
funcionarios entre ellos los ex
candidatos presidenciales josé antonio
meade y ricardo anaya de haber recibido
dinero de la empresa brasileña odebrecht
pero en al menos 12 países de américa en
uno de los casos de corrupción más
grandes de la historia
la constructora entregó miles de
millones de dólares para financiar
campañas a lo largo de todo el
continente a cambio de millonarios
contratos estatales uno de los más
simbólicos es el caso de perú en el que
tres ex presidentes fueron procesados en
mexico los hoyas el único detenido hasta
ahora
alrededor de 200 vacunas se están
desarrollando en el mundo para poner
freno al cob y 19 hay menos de 10 en la
fase 3 la última del proceso y la que
abre la puerta a su uso masivo una de
ellas es la que desarrolla la
universidad de oxford junto con el
laboratorio astrazéneca méxico y
argentina acordaron con este laboratorio
la fabricación de la vacuna para américa
latina en argentina se fabricará el
principio activo de esta inyección que
se distribuirá en la región nuestro
corresponsal natalio cosoi fue a conocer
la planta en la que se producirá
a 30 km al noroeste del centro de la
ciudad de buenos aires- se encuentra
esta planta donde se fabricará para toda
américa latina excepto brasil la vacuna
de la universidad de oxford y el
laboratorio astrazéneca para prevenir el
coi 19 pero el edificio no nació con ese
fin esta planta se había terminado de
construir en febrero de 2020 el objetivo
era y de hecho empezaron a hacerlo
fabricar productos para tratamientos
oncológicos pero unos meses después por
la pandemia cambio el plan
el tipo de tecnología necesario para una
y otra producción es similar y en su
corazón se encuentran estas estructuras
que contienen biorreactores en los que
se cultivo el material biológico para la
vacuna es una tecnología relativamente
reciente en el mundo y con la que
cuentan pocos laboratorios en toda
américa latina en argentina de una
planta así y pudo haber sido elegida
gracias a que existe y existe porque la
argentina tiene una vocación científica
tecnológica en sus profesionales en sus
científicos muy grandes
tiene científicos de calidad
biotecnólogos de calidad hay carrera de
biotecnología y la historia
biotecnológica argentina va un poquito
más adelante que en otros países de la
región en este lugar se fabricará el
principio activo que se enviara a méxico
donde se embasaran y distribuirán las
entre 150 y 250 millones de dosis que
prevén producir mientras siguen poniendo
punto a la planta aquí no dejan de
valorar lo histórico del momento que
están encarando y el lugar que ocupa en
sus carreras profesionales no bueno esto
está a tope
lejos va a ser difícil que aparezca otro
momento similar a este creo que para
cualquiera que trabaja en ciencias de la
vida como le decimos nosotros es el
mejor proyecto del mundo para que es muy
muy emocionante un proyecto que todavía
está en una etapa preparatoria poniendo
todo a punto para noviembre cuando
esperan hacer las primeras pruebas
escala para en febrero de 2021 si todo
sale bien producir los primeros lotes de
vacuna para toda la región
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho el coronavirus y si
pueden quedarse en casa viendo france24
[Música]
el espacio en france 20